A focus in Tasmania is to look at how
the devil may save itself through
evolution and
to accelerate that process.
Our research is showing that the devil is changing.
In the 10 years since disease we have seen a really big reduction in aggressive behaviour in devils.
Aggressive behaviour is associated with spreading the disease.
I think the best scenario for Tasmanian devils to be safe from extinction
is a combination of factors
and I don't think there's one solution or a silver bullet to avoid extinction
and that combination of factors are devil factors and tumour factors.
From the devil perspective they have to
learn, or be selected, to be less aggressive
to bite each other less and less often so
they're less likely to pass the disease
and from the tumour perspective also, the
tumour has to evolve into a tumour that
allows the Tasmanian devil to live long enough to create a next-generation,
to breed and put a new generation into the
population.
So I think there are parallel things happening together
that will decrease the likelihood of
extinction.